chapter 10 infinity
if the doors of perception were cleansed
everything would appear to man as it is
infinite william blake
there was something before the big bang
and that
something is what we will have in our
future
sir roger penrose
as above so below is a common aphorism
as we see
scale invariance very clearly in our
fractal universe
what surprises me more than anything is
how clearly the recursive nature of
reality
is under our noses yet hidden
the same way an acorn becomes an oak
tree which makes more acorns which
become
oak trees is the same way humans
birth babies which grow up to become
humans
that birth more babies is the same way
that reality
births more realities a cyclic
nature of infinite becoming
this would mean that we are
consciousness
exploring infinity an unbounded
map of experiences we have eternally
been doing this and will continue
forever
because it is impossible to reach the
end
we are the designers of this reality
we embedded the codes that slowly
titrate our
evolutionary awakening we came from the
metaverse
a synthesis of agi xr
simulation theory and it's exactly where
we are
going john smart calls this the
transcension hypothesis
which is a likely solution to the fermi
paradox
as donald hoffman says imagine a candy
store
there are an infinite combination of
flavors that you could never
finish experiencing embody
walt disney and imagine the creative
space
of being a universe designer
create a machine beautiful enough that a
soul
would want to live in it eugenia
infinite symphony i and my father are
one john 10 30.
it's all the same being meera alfasa
take benoit mandelbrot's infinite
fractal zoom
which you can find an incredible version
here on maths town
links in the bio now imagine that source
point
is constantly refracting infinite
combinations of
conscious agents evolving to experience
realities
use a limitless imagination think of
non-carbon-based
non-dna encoded life think of radically
different
sentience different math and physics
branching worlds where all of your
possibility space from seed theory
is being explored by different versions
of conscious agent u
source in essence is creativity
we are the publishers and the players
i would hypothesize that every
combinator
has an automata orthogenesis component
following a similar process to robert
may's logistic map
where we can program a deterministic
recursive
telos yet allow for a creative
unpredictable trajectory enabled by
incredible tools
like quantum theory which give rise to
free will for diverse
conscious agents in this ocean of
oneness
the ascension processes in these
creative combinatorics
are fueled by harmonic flux between
polarities
like we see in the science of helical
coils and electromagnetism
which perfectly correlates with ancient
spiritual wisdom traditions
like the yin yang archetype which has
been independently discovered across
cultures worldwide
so you begin to wonder are we all just
waking up
cyclically like civilizational eureka
moments
imagine an octave our symphony's
evolutionary pacer is playing between
e and f right now there
is no sharp the awakening from service
to self
sts to service to other sto
consciousness is learning how to play
in tune with the strange attractor
we designed
lastly i believe darwinian metaphysics
applies so recursion is not guaranteed
at the universal level the symphony
doesn't always make it past fermi
filters like asteroids
nuclear weapons planetary destruction
bio warfare
and agi there
are no bugs only features
we purposely designed all these
exhilarating creative
components and will especially be
awakening
in the 21st century with all the
metaverse technologies
being unleashed
consciousness exploring infinity
sakyon 2020